[Music]
can you guys imagine retiring at the age
of 25
25 that sounds boring yeah well our
buddies
they retired in late 20s but you could
go hang gliding
you go you could bungee jump uh
escalade i guess it depends on what kind
of retiring being young and rich
sounds awesome [ __ ] yeah yeah i'm into
that
right now at least everything you have
access to
true that'd be so fun right i go [ __ ]
and like like nobody's ever seen but
doesn't that mean you spent all your
retirement money then
if you already did that you could you're
responsible maybe
if you got there there's no way you're
blowing all that money [ __ ] like maybe
five
five times a month cut back on your horn
a little bit i'm cutting back a little
bit you got a budget you're whoring yeah
i'm coming back once a year well here i
have a story of this
this 25 year old who unfortunately had
to retire
who james smith fortunately
no so this guy here he had to retire
because of
an injury a good one he no longer
is able to do his career because of this
injury
what so he had to retire at the age of
25 what's his career
he is a professional video game player
and so he had a thumb injury oh
[ __ ] yeah wait i've seen people play
[ __ ] guitar hero with like
their feet inside you know so he needed
his thumb he's making an excuse
i don't know if it's an excuse because i
mean when you click a mouse
competition-wise though
well yeah competition-wise right oh
right competition
all right well i guess because you're
yeah i'm sure he still plays video games
but just not competitively yeah so he
ended up
uh announcing his retirement saying that
he will no longer compete in competitive
call of duty for the foreseeable future
he's been playing since he was 18. so
he's been
like professionally since he was 18. how
did he injure his thumb i
he should have got it insured yeah like
a hand model
yup yeah or like didn't halle berry do
that to her whole body or some [ __ ]
jayla got her ass cheeks oh that's who
it was it was jayla
do football players insure any parts of
their body i think so i don't even think
they qualify though
yeah can they can they try their brain i
don't think they can
i think you take an insurance there's a
higher deductible there was a baseball
player
his name was matt harrington i think and
he he was a huge bust
but he basically got his arm insured or
some [ __ ] like that and he was able to
cash out a huge policy even though he
was a [ __ ] bust
i feel like baseball players can but
like football like the nature of the
sport is just crushing each other isn't
it yeah good point
i don't know yeah cause like baseball
guys they get injured and they still get
paid out pretty good
where like like football guys are like
done i think that anybody will sell you
insurance for anything though
that's true like i think antonio brown
got his feet like insured somehow or
something i don't remember what it was
crazy yeah so this guy we're talking
about here his name is thomas papparado
and he plays under the name zuma for the
new york
for the new york sub liners esports team
this is what he looks like
wow kind of looks like um
zayn malik zayn malik how do you hold a
microphone like this
you're funny joe i mean it matches the
sweater so i guess
it matches the sweater the finger nail
polish when you were first pitching the
story i could kind of see that out of my
periphery and i thought he retired from
stand-up
like for from an injury i was like oh
god it would be interesting yeah what
kind of injury would make your retire
stand out right
avoid vocals cut off your injuries just
give you more material
yeah right no but i guess like that
would force you to retire
i guess it would be like a vocal thing
right you can't speak i don't know
come out with a voice thing i knew a
stand-up who had tourette's and he still
did stand up so
[ __ ] yeah i don't think so because i
feel like stand up it takes a comical
brain
and you're and then like i think
comedians they'll stop at nothing to get
comedy out
so even if their vocal cords are gone
they'll probably hire someone
to maybe deliver it for them while
they're on stage or they might do sign
language
or they might type it out huh juggling
communicate through juggles comedic
juggling
yeah they'll do whatever it takes is
that what uh carrot top did
he tried i wonder how he's doing in
vegas they're not doing shows anymore
oh yeah what's he up to maybe lifting
he's been pretty jacked for the last 10
years oh yeah yeah
well what kind of is he dressed by
looking at you
he does look scary he looks so scared
how did he get from goofy to intense his
face
i think he got made fun of so much or
something is he wearing makeup
oh yeah he does wear makeup too or at
least it looks like a joker
yeah like i feel like las vegas dried
him up a little bit
maybe gotta get a humidifier oh is his
body's so weird i think he got made fun
of way too much and he's like i'm not
taking any more from anybody
oh [ __ ] yeah i mean he can't blame other
people he named himself carrot top
there's some jacked photos
hold on dad he looks jacked right there
this isn't as jacked as you know
like you're talking about the billboard
one jacked up look at this [ __ ]
look at this [ __ ] [ __ ] holy [ __ ] oh
come on dude that's carrot top
he doesn't even wear underwear she just
said she'd [ __ ] her top no
dude look at that look at this look at
how his pants is look at the v
you like that [ __ ] oh yeah that is his
belt is being is being held up by one
pubic hair
his monkey muscles if he does one
jumping jack his dick's popping out oh
yeah
yeah that's really low geez you know
what i'm saying his dick's jacked too
but
[Laughter]
if he turns around did you see his butt
crack like why is he yeah it looks like
his butt cracks out his name should be
carrot [ __ ]
i could see it he does look like how did
he turn into a
a a woman do you think he's like you
want to meet the carrot
it's like he's like this crazy
like soldier from the neck down but his
face became more feminine
it's the makeup i think oh that's what
it is botox
so what happened to this guy how did he
get his thumb got chopped off
we're on top dude come on okay so
interesting thing about canton
yeah i don't know exactly if there was
like one incident but it just seems as
though it was like over time he just
wore his thumb out like arthritis for
his thoughts he did
have to like take some time off like
and just it just ended up causing more
damage by using the thumb
we'll see xbox playstation or pc player
i don't know it sounds like it's
definitely a controller
because you don't need your thumbs for
the pc yeah so we probably xbox you have
that elite controller
where you can swap out the parts you
know about that he's using one thumb
more than the other thumb
yeah maybe it's the one like for the
camera i don't know you got carpal
thummel
probably yeah yeah i don't know i
definitely had a thumb
thumb [ __ ] what did what happened after
having isaac
i think it was this one i keep
forgetting you're carrying him wrong
this thing i had a swollen
tendon like it was like a protruding
tendon you could literally see it here
and then it would like pop
you mean after you had them after when
you popped them out that's like common
it's common
really did you get it i did not but it's
kind of it's like arthritis
yeah because geo got into something
about it being inflamed so when she
would bench
like even holding like the bar it would
hurt her thumb during pregnancy
after like you like there's something
happens to your joints where like
it swells up after yeah exactly after
having a kid
that's why
[Laughter]
there's definitely a gamer muscles that
you don't get otherwise if you're not
playing video games
like if i don't play video games or
anything for like months or whatever and
i'm like oh i should play some video
games today
like after playing for like no like 30
minutes you're like wow my
arms hurt from trying to play wow
because like you don't normally do this
like a lot what about your typing
i mean unless you're a professional
typer oh you know like you're just
typing some here and there
hello i [ __ ] type for hours yeah and
but
like imagine not typing at all and then
you go back and you need to really fast
for a long time
it's like little muscles in your in your
forearms my
my thumb does hurt sometimes from
swiping on the phone just hanging out
just chilling actually my elbows hurt
from holding it like that like holding
my phone
oh yes where do you put it where do you
rest them on your knees
um no like just by holding my phone
like this oh [ __ ] that's what that looks
like yeah yeah just by holding
like just having it bent so when i fall
asleep yeah
i have to and then i also like to fall
asleep like this so i'm constantly
bending
my arms like this yeah so then sometimes
i have to like just
sleep like this because my elbows are
killing me so even now do you use your
phone like this for after a while
just something no i should get a
magnifying glass and put it
i should though but no i don't but yeah
i don't know oh and then when i played
animal crossing
for like all that time my thumbs were
hurting
for like [ __ ] using the the buttons
and [ __ ] mm-hmm do you think that like
pro
gamer like whether you if you're the
spouse of a pro gamer
that when you're watching the game like
you're truly proud of this person
like as they're like in a championship
match or some [ __ ] hell yeah if you know
it's bringing in money
i mean my husband that's something no
it's so interesting though to me because
i like
you watch the super bowl and like you
see like the wife is up there with the
kids and like
and like the guy throws the touchdown
and everyone understands what that is
but then i'm watching call of duty war
zone or some [ __ ] and i'm like what the
[ __ ] is going on
i imagine it's like uh like watching
queen's gambit but call of duty yeah
yeah i mean i get excited just watching
isaac play like whenever we're doing uh
i don't know we used to play like rocket
league or i forgot what other games
but whenever we would play games like i
would be hyping oh
when we would play crash bandicoot
because i was teaching him like that
game because that's like my
generation game so i was showing him
that game and so when he would get
like a certain combo right i'd be like
[ __ ] yeah like i would like try to
give him heads up on what's coming so
he's like focus on each thing in front
of him but i'm like telling him like
okay
now upcoming there's gonna be like three
boxes to your left he's like well i
can't see it because the graphics suck
ass mom
but like you do get hyped no you get it
yeah i get it
okay especially if there's money
involved dude yeah you never seen a dog
surf competition
those get me hype competition there's
enough surfing dogs for them
all these bulldogs or whatever and then
the dogs get on the surfboard and then
they
[ __ ] ride they do it themselves no
they gotta get pushed
so they also they get pushed i see them
oh that's not as cool but they got like
at least like stuff too skateboarding
dogs can push themselves [ __ ]
lazy-ass surfing dogs
dude the other day i saw freaking i saw
two monkeys on a power wheel jeep
with a [ __ ] chihuahua in the back
seat in real life
on a video i wish i saw it in real life
right and then this monkey [ __ ]
rolled up
and then they hit a car and they're like
oh [ __ ] and then when he backed up he
did one of these
oh [ __ ] i think i saw that video yeah
and then the
the the monkey that was in passenger
looked back and then making sure that
the puppy was okay
yeah and i was like dude this is like
they're like hairy people this is crazy
how are we not living in a simulation
when you say that
[ __ ] sentence and you actually have
to see that with your eyes exactly
i think that's the reason why we're not
in a simulation because it's so crazy
whenever joe tells these stories i'm
like our instagram feeds are totally
different yeah
that's true huh have you ever looked at
your discover thing
and then you know how the algorithm is
supposed to tell you what it is
but on steroids right so mine is like
a ton of girls bikes
cars and i'm like what the [ __ ]
but i follow you guys though you're a 13
year old boy that's what that says
exactly explore pages really tell a lot
about a person it doesn't really nail
mine really really yeah
should we all just pull it up right now
and see what they look like every time
i've said that
i don't like what it does no mine is
like off because
for me it's always like girls it's
always kardashians and rings like
it's always like engagement rings i'm
like what the [ __ ] i don't even look
that [ __ ] up
do you look up jk news articles on your
phone maybe it thinks you're like
looking at pop culture or something
you're looking up kardashians that's
probably what it is kardashians are
always in my my explore page
look there's even a surfer girl with one
arm
dude i mean where's the one on one
the one that's surfing yeah it's all
tall babes and motorcycles
and babes on motorcycles there we go
it's all babes right there
i made the terrible mistake of uh
watching and food star wars lightsaber
battle videos
on instagram and that was all of that
now it thinks not only do i want to
watch this but i want to buy
lightsabers and i'm like oh you kind of
do oh [ __ ] that's the
[ __ ] i do you know i want to do a
lightsaber battle
well dude there's leagues and [ __ ] dude
you can join a jedi academy and
i've seen it go down you've seen it in
real life yeah
i i i knew one of the guys you met this
dude too
and he was a part of the group called
the san diego sabres
dude i follow those cats yeah yeah and
then they they have meetups
and they have showdowns and
and it's it's like a whole league dude
it's pretty crazy
the way that they're very seriously
looking at each other before the duels
start yeah
it makes me laugh harder than they even
the duels themselves because they're in
it dude
they're [ __ ] locked in young padawan
editor mode bro that's funny
yeah see my explore page is weird like
there's
engagement rings here there's like
crystals and
astrology [ __ ] and i do watch cake
decorating videos a lot why is that
weird you're into all those things i
look at this and i'm like yeah i think
it could be texas
and stuff oh i thought you weren't or
any of that no i'm not i mean
nikki links you things when you click on
them i do i do like a lot of these like
before
after like uh home improvement stuff
like or
diy things but then there's a lot of
like
but it's also like people you like like
the post if someone else liked crystals
or
astrology then it's like oh you like
that [ __ ] is this it's just your
friendship with nikki alone just
unfollow nikki that's the only way
is that a sea slug yeah it's like it's
like a fish eating a slug or something
that's probably me
but that's also because you like i think
you like um the oddly satisfying videos
and that's kind of in that
oh yeah but oh my god oddly satisfying
could be so hit or miss
because like sometimes it's [ __ ]
repulsive and i'm like why is this
status like
and you watch every single one no i
don't i click away immediately but yeah
my
my explore page is not it's not it's not
me
anybody watch any sick [ __ ] like you
watch like [ __ ] zits getting popped
and [ __ ] oh
no yeah i can't i can't even do it no
thank you i'm into julia
i can kind of get into ingrown hair
removal sometimes
but i gotta be in the mood for it
specific mood
[Music]
you